Every Hanukkah Jewish people around the world retell the legendary story of Judah and the Maccabees but hundreds of years ago many Jews also,
celebrated the story of Judith and a severed head
The story begins it was the twelfth year of the reign of Nebuchadnezzar
Who ruled over the Assyrians in the great city of Nineveh because Nebuchadnezzar took power in a 605 BCE
We know our story starts in 593 BCE Nebuchadnezzar
Is at war with our Fox on a median King ruling over an empire in ancient Iran
Nebuchadnezzar asks other nations to join him in his fight against our Fox odd
but nobody bites
But it doesn't matter because five years later
Nebuchadnezzar defeats our Fox odd on his own and vows to destroy those nations who did not join him
The next year he sends Holofernes his most loyal general to carry out this campaign of revenge
Holofernes and his massive army crushed any resistance in his way until there is only one nation left the Kingdom of Judah
Holofernes wants to capture Jerusalem, but his path is blocked by the small town of Bethulia instead of fighting
The Israelites Holofernes cuts off the thule 'as water supply
34 days later the people of Bethulia are ready to surrender
But Isaiah the town magistrate convinces the people to wait five more days for God to rescue them
Enter Judith a beautiful pious Widow living in Bethulia
She's angered by the idea of setting a time limit on God's work and scolds the town's leaders for doing so but they are
Suffering so Judith promises to carry out a deed that will be known from generation to generation
That night Judith and her handmaiden leave the town for Holofernes camp
They convinced the Assyrians that they are ready to betray their fellow Jews and want to share information with Allah ferny's
Judith and her maids spend the next four days with the Assyrians when Holofernes invites Judith to a banquet
Knowing that Holofernes was attempting to seduce her Judith dresses in her finest clothing and jewelry
She seduces the general into eating cheese and wine a lot of wine
More than he had ever drunk on any day since he was born
Holofernes passes out on his bed Judith takes challah for sword and makes her move saying
Now is the time to shatter the enemies who have risen against us
and
cuts off his head
Judith Ann, her maid escaped the Assyrian cab Holofernes head in tow
She returns to Bethulia a hero holding up the head for the whole town to see
the Assyrians meanwhile
Discover the headless Holofernes on the floor of his tent the camp goes into a panic and most of the troops scatter the Israelite army
Plunders what is left and kills the stragglers?
Judith continued to live as a widow in Bethulia and died at the ripe old age of 105 the story ends by saying
No one attacked the Israelites during or in the time after Judith's life. However, this isn't reflected in the historical record
in fact, a lot of Judith's story isn't
Remember how we said our story began in 593 BCE because it was the 12th year of Nebuchadnezzar's rule
Well the great city of Nineveh had already been destroyed in 612 BCE Nineveh was the capital of the Assyrian Empire
So when it fell so did the Empire and who destroyed it. It was Nebuchadnezzar himself
because he was a Babylonian king and the Assyrians were actually his arch enemies and he had just destroyed their capital later when
Holofernes seeks to attack Jerusalem well in reality
Nebuchadnezzar had already been besieging Jerusalem for the past two years and Bethulia Judith's town
No one really remembers where Bethulia was and it's only mentioned in this story as for the ending where the Jews live happily ever after
Nebuchadnezzar and the Babylonians actually destroyed Jerusalem in 587 BCE and
Ended the kingdom of Judah pretty much the opposite of what the story describes
Perhaps because of that the book of Judith wasn't included in Jewish Holy Scripture
but her story
persisted and Jews in medieval Europe would retell it during Hanukkah due to the themes it shares with the story of Judah Maccabee in
some oral traditions
Judith was even recast as Judah Maccabees aunt or daughter and like Judith and Holofernes tent they would eat cheese as part of their festive
meal often frying it in oil
While most Jews today now fry potatoes to make latkes during Hanukkah others still use cheese out of family tradition
even if the reason why has been long forgotten
You